service de valets pour personnes à
mobilité réduite nous sommes à l'hôtel
non à l'hôpital
vous cherchez le bureau de votre médecin
voici comment s'y rendre
un trajet qu'on télécharge sur son
téléphone
vous êtes dans un hôpital tout neuf de
kaiser dans tous leurs réseaux il y a
dix sept mille médecins dont la pédiatre
amende à kaloum qui rencontre sarah
wright schreiber john maman eu des 10
millions patiente kaiser remarqué ce que
fait docteur calhoun coup d'oeil à
l'ordinateur
car c'est là une de leurs grandes
particularités
chaque patient à son dossier médical
informatisé
c'est le coeur de ma pratique nous dit
le docteur calhoun toute l'information
médicale et la résultats test rayons x
rendez vous et tous les médecins 15e y
ont accès un seul dossier pour tout le
monde ça a été salvateur pour sarah
avant d'être maman elle a été frappé par
le cancer et a eu des mois traitement
n'est pas eu à craindre que le médecin
n'est pas la même information
je n'ai pas eu à transporter mon dossier
médical de médecins à l'autre je n'ai
pas eu non plus à me soucier de cela
alors que je vivais des moments
difficiles
ils ont des ordinateurs les médecins 15e
très bien alors qu'on patients vous
pouvez leur envoyer des courriels vous
pouvez même ajouter des photos pour
montrer vos petits bobos
vont-ils répondre rapidement on est aux
deux jours dit le docteur clown est
utile les courriels quand on traite un
cancer d'ailleurs je devais communiquer
avec plusieurs médecins et c'était
génial de pouvoir échanger avec eux par
courriel alors que souvent je me sentais
trop malade pour me déplacer ou même
parlé au téléphone
ça m'a vraiment aidé j'ai toujours
obtenu des réponses rapides à memorial
bravo mais si le médecin répond à des
courriels au lieu de faire venir le
patient à son bureau il ne pourra pas
lui facturer une visite pas besoin les
médecins 15 ne sont pas rémunérés à
l'acte
ils sont tous des salariés fat ou
d'autres aides
j'adore le fait qu'on ne soit pas payé à
la visite les gens travaillent et n'ont
pas toujours le temps de se déplacer
s'ils ne viennent pas en personne c'est
une bonne chose pour eux et pour moi
le docteur patricia qu'on allait
pratiquer la médecine check raiser et
occupe un poste de cadre populaire 15e
chez les médecins
elle nous dit que lord embauche elle
reçoit environ dix candidatures par
postes disponibles premier attrait pour
vouloir devenir médecin salarié dit-elle
se concentrer sur sa pratique plutôt que
de ce souci d'avoir à gérer une
entreprise
pourquoi quand je préfère avoir des
médecins salariés plutôt que des
médecins qui facturent à l'acte la cadac
les médecins qui facturent à l'acte ne
sont pas mal intentionnés qui est basée
sur le fait que le passé on doit se
présenter à leur bureau pour qu'ils
soient rémunérés les médecins salariés
n'ont pas cette contrainte quand vient
le temps de décider de la meilleure
façon de traiter un patient ockrent en
face de san francisco 7 heures du matin
personne n'est au travail au siège de
kaiser personne sauf lui qu'on pourrait
appeler le ministre de la santé
il ne s'appelle pas barrette mais
cournoyer de descendance canadienne
française est devenue aujourd'hui
cornouaille à il est vice président et
médecin en chef alors comme grand patron
des médecins il leur demande d'avoir
combien patients convient il a dit 2000
à 2500 c'est bien ce qu'il a dit c'est
pas un peu trop
max ça dépend de la façon dont vous
organisez le soutien au médecin
ce n'est pas trop si vous comparez ce
qui se fait ailleurs aux états unis pour
un médecin généraliste 2500 patients par
médecin
ça n'a rien d'inhabituel
c'est l'un des aspects fondamentaux de
15 e les médecins font de la médecine et
ils ont dû soutien il y à des
infirmières des assistants des
gestionnaires qui voit ce que les
patients reçoivent les bons soins alors
le nombre de patients attribués aux
médecins 50 du fait qu'il aura le
soutien de toute une équipe bien soutenu
et salariés alors est-ce qu'il travaille
beaucoup en gros un médecin travaille du
lundi au vendredi de 8 heures à 18
heures un ou deux jours de garde par
mois soit cette semaine trois à quatre
semaines de vacances annuelles une à
deux semaines de plus pour de la
formation avec 125 1000 employés et 70
ans d'existence kaiser a eu son lot de
difficultés à mende recours collectif un
de ces syndicats particulièrement
militants dénoncent une course à la
réduction des services pour augmenter
les bénéfices de l'entreprise normande
toujours plus de profits ils ont des
réserves de 32 milliards ils ont fait
des profits records au cours des cinq
dernières années 15 milliards au total
la direction priorise le service minimal
au détriment des soins adéquats
ce à quoi elle répond qu'elle est une
entreprise à but non lucratif et que les
bénéfices servent à financer de nouveaux
équipements comme la construction
d'hôpitaux 9 et que ke ne doit pas être
si mauvais puisqu'un organisme
indépendant d'évaluation des régimes
d'assurance de santé lui donne des
quatre étoiles avec la mention excellent
de la trop santé non 13 reconnaît que
son système n'est pas parfait
wikio experts nos coûts sont trop élevés
on n'obtient pas les résultats
on aimerait et d'autres pays arrive à
faire mieux avec les ressources dont il
dispose
alors on a autant à apprendre à
enseigner
kaiser c'est un régime d'assurance
privées auxquelles on adhère soit par
son employeur soit à titre individuel la
prime minimale pour un jeune célibataire
en santé et 200 dollars par mois alors
que pour une jeune famille de quatre
personnes
ces 600 dollars par mois pour passer à
l'hôpital il faut d'abord passer à la
caisse
tout un contraste quand même avec le
système québécois demain je recevrai le
ministre guettant barrettes pour lui
dire de quelle idée du modèle kaiser il
compte s'inspirer
mais aussi pour répondre aux critiques
sur sa réforme de la santé